bonsoir bienvenue dans le journal de tv
78 de votre condensé d'actualité locale
voici les titres de ce jeudi 18 mars
l'ile-de-france fixé sur son sort ce
soir jean castex doit annoncer de
nouvelles mesures pour faire face à
l'épidémie de kobe 19 confinement strict
le week-end ou simple durcissement
l'exécutif hésite invités de cette
édition le docteur laurent de bastard
vice président de l'ordre des médecins
des yvelines et arnaud péricard maire de
saint germain en laye et 10 millions de
touristes s'y pressaient chaque année
versailles subi de plein fouet les
conséquences de la crise sanitaire les
hôtels restaurants et commerces tourne
au ralenti et doivent se réinventer pour
survivre et puis cette inauguration
marque officiellement la fin des travaux
de la rd 30 la passerelle du bois de la
crâne a été mise en service à plaisir
elle permet de relier le bois avec le
parc du château c'était la dernière
étape du chantier d'élargissement de
l'accès routier est démarré il y a 6 ans
l ile de france sera t-elle re confiné
c'est la question que tous les
franciliens se pose ce soir alors que
doit prendre la parole le premier
ministre pour faire des annonces sur la
crise sanitaire
hier mercredi emmanuel macron à échanger
sur le sujet avec les élus locaux après
avoir visité le centre hospitalier de
poissy saint germain en laye confinement
total seulement le week-end ou réduction
du couvre feu ou encore des mesures plus
innovantes tous les scénarios sont
évoqués dans ce contexte très tendu à
l'hôpital concernant le qu'ovide 19 nos
deux invités du soir le docteur laurent
de bastard bonsoir médecin urgentiste à
l'hôpital privé de versailles vous êtes
également le vice président de l'ordre
des médecins des yvelines également avec
nous en visioconférence arnaud péricard
bonsoir bonsoir maire de la ville de
saint-germain-en-laye vous fait
également partie de l'association des
maires d'ile-de-france vous en êtes l'un
des vice-présidents et vous avez fait
partie de ces élus qui ont pu échanger
hier avec le président de la république
on va en parler dans un instant avec
nous également bixente mayence insisté
ban de la rédaction de tv 78 soir
bonsoir
une situation donc très alarmante
bixente dans les hôpitaux franciliens
oui en effet deux cas le 8 mars dernier
la rs ile-de-france a demandé la
déprogrammation de 40% des opérations
médicales et chirurgicales
une conséquence de la forte hausse du
taux d'incidence des quinze derniers
jours dans la région
l'objectif c'est de libérer du personnel
et du matériel pour pouvoir armer le
plus de lits possible preuve de la
pression actuelle sur les hôpitaux les
101,2 % de taux d'occupation des lits en
île de france par rapport à la capacité
initiale avant la crise une tension qui
est donc à son paroxysme et dans les
yvelines 72 passion était en réanimation
hier mercredi exactement donc nous avons
interrogé eric luz directeur de
l'hôpital privé de versailles pour
savoir comment les trois hôpitaux
yvelinois du groupe ram santé
s'organiser face à cette situation on
écoute
nous avons fait le choix au niveau du
pôle ile de france ouest finalement de
permettre de concentrer la prise en
charge des patients atteints du coc vide
sur l'hôpital cru et de l'ouest parisien
et sur l'hôpital privé de parly 2
et de récupérer le personnel de l'ach pv
pour pouvoir les détachés sur ces deux
établissements
donc comme lors du premier confinement
les hôpitaux des programmes toutes les
opérations pouvant être repoussée ils
maintiennent bien entendu les
interventions dites à perte de chance ou
celle de patients atteints de maladies
chroniques
est ce qu'on peut craindre une situation
comparable voire même pire à celle du
premier confinement bien la différence
de la situation en mars dernier les
hôpitaux franciliens ne bénéficient plus
de renforts de médecins venus des
provinces pour prendre en charge les
pubs plus de patients une véritable
course contre la montre donc avec chaque
jour de nouveaux patients qui entrent en
réanimation
pour le directeur de l'alsh pvr et
klouche le confinement semblent donc
inévitables lors de la précédente
itération le confinement a été permis
rapidement d'avoir un effet plateau est
également de réduire très
significativement le nombre d'admissions
et donc de libérer des lits je pense
qu'aujourd'hui il va être compliqué de
ne pas de ne pas lancer ou à d'activer
effectivement un nouveau confinement
alors après dans quelle mesure je ne
sais pas mais je pense que que le sujet
est nécessaire le merci bixente pour
toutes ces précisions alors confinement
total ou simplement le week-end et ce
cas votre avis docteur de basterds c'est
la seule solution possible pour éviter
ou en tout cas à endiguer cette
troisième vague dont a parlé le premier
ministre jean castex
alors on s'est fait des sujets complexes
arrière tout le monde il va de son
commentaire
ce qui est certain c'est sont les
vaccinations est un des moyens sûrs
d'eux
d'endiguer en soit cette épidémie et
puis continuer les gestes barrière qui
sont aussi un des moyens efficaces de
faire en sorte qu'ils aient moins que
l'épidémie marque pas alors après la
déprogrammation
elle est une sécurité c'est à dire qu'on
voit en effet aujourd'hui d'augmentation
c'est ce que vous disiez de du taux
d'incidence
donc il ya une occupation des lits qui
est de plus en plus importante et on
craint en effet d'être submergé donc il
ya eu
vous avez vu en fin de semaine dernière
quelques patients qui ont été transférés
dans d'autres hôpitaux en province mais
pour l'instant ça tient
on voit que les durées d'hospitalisation
par rapport à la première vague sont
beaucoup moins importants ce qui fait
que on il ya un turnover dans les lits
qui fait qu' on peut reprendre des
nouveaux patients
on a quand même ouvert un certain nombre
de lits d'hospitalisation les
établissements privés aussi avait joué
le jeu lors de la première à la première
vague ils le font sur la deuxième et la
troisième
comme disait eric louche le directeur du
pôle hors mc général il ya dans le pool
souhaite rétablissement il y en a deux
qui sont des réacs vide et en effet vous
avez moi je serai au service des
urgences aranda d'infirmières et
d'infirmiers qui sont partis pour aller
sur les réanimations de ceux des
établissements
donc il ya une organisation qui se fait
sur les hôpitaux de la même façon on
essaie de faire sortir le plus
rapidement possible bien sûr ces
patients de réanimation ce qu'il faut
c'est éviter bien sûr qu'ils y arrivent
c'est surtout ça donc c'est ça après des
programmations
on a déplu aux médecins la
déprogrammation c'est inquiétant dans le
sens où ça fait peur au gens parce qu'
il dise à partie du mouron des
programmes c'est qu'il ya un risque à
l'hôpital c'est que l'épidémie augmenté
que en venant à l'hôpital il ya des
patients qu'aux vide et qu'on réalise
d'être contaminés et on sait que déjà
sur la première règle ya eu beaucoup de
finalement de gens qui il va y avoir une
ce mortal it et on va voir des gens qui
arrivent souvent d'errements et on l'a
vu parce qu'ils avaient des pathologies
graves parce qu'ils sont pas fait
diagnostiquer parce qu'ils n'ont pas
voulu se faire dépister et donc une
retard de prise en charge est donc une
mortalité plus importante des
pathologies qui aurait pu dire que ce
qui était précédemment
donc ça c'est saissac et qui est
inquiétant quand on des programmes parce
qu'on dit on des programmes que le
fonctionnaire que le
le fonctionnel c'est à dire des gens qui
ont besoin de se faire opérer mais qui
aurait pu se faire opérer dans trois
quatre cinq mois ça sert en effet s'il
n'y a pas d'urgence à ce qu'elle sait
qu'il ya certains personnes qui refusent
ou qui retarde de leurs interventions
qui sont urgentes ou où des coloscopies
de dépistage ou d'examens dépistage qui
sont indispensables et est utile parce
qu'ils ont peur de venir à l'hôpital
votre réaction aussi à cette actualité
vous parlez de la vaccination tout à
l'heure l'agencé européenne du
médicament a donné son feu vert pour la
poursuite de la vaccination avec
astrazeneca à la france avait interdit
est suspendu en tout cas provisoirement
son utilisation lundi l agence
européenne du médicament a dit que le
vaccin était sûr et efficace qui n'avait
pas de lien avec les cas de caillots
sanguins qui ont été révélés c'est une
bonne nouvelle pour la campagne de
vaccination vous en tant que médecin
libéral vous vacciner à la strada n'est
qu'un médecin libéral aux médecins
hospitaliers
l'italie également parce que j'ai les
deux pieds mais installé nous moi ce que
j'aime ce qui est intéressant c'est que
par exemple au moins du réveillon
je passe le réveillon dans les
conditions de sécurité avec des médecins
prochain de la paix qui disait à nonant
mois le finder
on n'a pas assez de recul on sait pas et
cetera on verra j'attendrai pour me
faire vacciner et finalement donc ça
c'était le 31 et le 15 janvier
tout le monde s'est rué chez et ses
médecins l'a été vaccinés et moi dès que
j'ai eu la possibilité en effet dès
début janvier je me suis fait vacciner
le premier vaccin est en phase iib
rejeté vacciner sur le kaiser parce que
j'étais dans les conditions d'âge et et
de ce qu'il fallait pour être vaccinés
mais quand ton profil de santé et alors
la partie du monde avait vu l'engouement
des professionnels de santé qui sont
venues se faire vacciner sur le plaisir
tout le monde a voulu aller sur le
phaser à la sur la cerise année car il
ya eu des lieux il ya eu assez vite on a
dit ah ben non astrazeneca match du
fight the pale d'astrazeneca etc et on
sait on avait dit fender leisen avait
dit on pourra pas provisionné en
quantité suffisante les pays qui avaient
précommandé là serait délicat donc on
savait qu'on serait on sent en
difficulté pour la voir on a vu au début
donc une certaine réticence et puis
beaucoup de gens sont venus se faire
vacciner et était très heureux de se
faire vacciner il ya eu ce stop je pense
que c'est
mais bon c'était un peu une obligation
parce que l'allemagne notre partenaire
historique et cetera avait dit qu'il
attendait pour voir aujourd'hui on est
rassuré parce que je pense que en effet
ce vaccin est un vaccin sur moi j'ai
vacciner à la fois en établissement
parce que les prochains de santé de
moins de 50 ans sont sur l'astra zeneca
alors le seul inconvénient c'est qu'en
effet des effets secondaires sont un peu
plus forts c'est à dire vous avez en
effet dans 20% des cas d des fièvres un
peu un peu forte avec des signes des
signes de stores de la fièvre maux de
tête etc
mais c'est un vaccin qui est qui a
prouvé son efficacité on a un recul
important parce que l'angleterre a
vacciné de façon très importante depuis
autres quatre mois et c'est une bonne
chose et il faut qu en effet je pense
que clairement les français il faut y
aller tout de suite il faut pas attendre
un prochain élection parce que les
quantités seront pas suffisantes sur les
vaccins ils viendront et le vaccin
français ça serait con bête dommage on a
compris que c'était une bonne nouvelle
en eau péricard qui est également avec
nous en visioconférence maire de saint
germain en laye je disais tout à l'heure
vous avez participé à cet entretien en
visioconférence hier avec le président
de la république comme onze autres
maires des yvelines déjà sur la forme ce
qui est plutôt appréciable de pouvoir
échanger directement avec le président
de la république avant de dire ce qui
est ce qui a été dit au cours de cet
entretien permettra peut-être juste à
titre liminaire de saluer le le docteur
de bastard ici présent ça est presqu'un
an que nous collaborons si je puis dire
et j'apprécie vraiment l'appui que le
conseil de l'ordre travers l'association
de la 78 apporte aux collectivités
locales ne sommes pas des sachants ne
sort pas des médecins et je crois qu'il
est rassurant d'avoir aussi nos
professionnels de santé impliqués aux
côtés des collectivités alors oui nous
avons eu un échange hier effectivement
un chef de l'état certains d'entre nous
échange régulièrement avec muscler mon
casque et cas également de du maire de
possibles karl olive et je crois que
c'était importantes qu'ils entendent ces
maires franciliens c'est mary vinoy lui
remonter la manière dont nous vivons de
cette prime
quotidiennement dans nos habitants aussi
la vie mais il nous a interrogés sur
effectivement quelle mesure quel
dispositif pourrait être mise en oeuvre
et puis on a eu un long rush ans a duré
presque deux heures et je pense que cet
échange c'est un outil d aide à la
décision que le président pourra
utiliser des mesures qui sera celle ici
un peu moins d'une heure maintenant et
sur ce scénario dur confinement en ile
de france vous confirmer que c'est celui
qui ne semblait pas privilégier le
président de la république ya des choses
qui ont filtré
comme quoi il était plus favorable à des
solutions plus hybride si le chilien
oui je crois que il ya peut-être deux
certitudes
encore une fois peut-être serais-je
démenti dans moins d'une heure il y
avait deux certitudes la première c'est
que il ya un particularisme franciliens
je crois que personne ne peut
aujourd'hui revenir là dessus il ya plus
de 12 millions d'habitants des zones de
densification urbaine qui sont très
forts et c'est le poumon économique du
pays
quand vous confier l'ile-de-france vous
confiner la france entière donc bien
évidemment que ce sont des mesures qu'il
faut prendre la main tremblante si je
puis dire donc la première des
certitudes
et oui il ya une particularité sur l'île
de france et la deuxième c'est que il ya
un besoin d'oxygénation du week-end il
ya un besoin voilà de prendre en compte
cette difficulté que nous avons la
difficulté de la vie quotidienne des
franciliens lé pape
elle est pas belle du lundi au vendredi
le travail 7 ans ification ce stress
aussi du quotidien
et puis ce temps du week-end qui doit
être aussi un temps de repos on peut pas
avoir la double peine je crois que ça 6
7 ans tout en nous indiquant qu'il
fallait des mesures de freinage
importantes en ile-de-france avec le
premier tout ça dans le même sac
qu'est ce qu'il en ressort bien malin
celui qui effectivement peut vous dire
par anticipation ce qui va se passer
mais en tout cas sur le week-end c'était
une quasi certitude mais vous avez
milité vous pour garder les forêts les
parcs et jardins accessibles
oui moi je ne me reconnaissent toujours
pas du traumatisme de ce premier
confinement quand la forêt de
saint-germain 3800 hectares a été servi
du jour au lendemain
c'est pas évident de faire vite fort et
quand on nous a demandé de fermer le
parc du château de saint germain quand
on nous a demandé de fermer des squares
et j'ai trouvé ça complètement
incohérent alors même demandé aux
habitants de se distancier rappelez-vous
le temps qu'il faisait il ya un an
il faisait très beau il a fait beau
pendant longtemps tu et je pense que ce
premier compliment peut-être aurait été
mieux vécu sur n'avait permis cette
oxygénation et cette distanciation
planaire on aura les réponses aux
alentours de 19h pour scène ses
nouvelles mesures restrictives
une petite dernière question arnaud
péricard sur la vaccination depuis
janvier il ya un centre de vaccination
sur la commune de saint germain ce même
un centre de communes de de vaccination
intercommunal avec four q où en
sommes-nous sur place c'est ce que
beaucoup beaucoup d'habitants ont pu
être vaccinés à ce genre écouter sur les
presque 8000 vaccination qui ont injecté
y ont été faites
voilà il ya environ 30% qui ont été
destinés à l'agglomération s'avère un
peu de sel en pourcent sur la population
saint germanoise et le reste c'est 40%
et un mec ya pas de sécurisation
géographique des habitants yvelinois
mais aussi des parisiens aussi des
habitants des des hauts-de-seine on est
très remontés en puissance on en a parlé
que le président hier on a parlé à m
l'agencé régionale de santé et une forte
montée en puissance qui est attendue
pour dans une grosse dizaine de jours
donc tous nos centres sont prévus pour
monter en capacité
on a ouvert sa ville en début de semaine
on va ouvrir le 29
cette lourde rate 60 dans notre
communauté d'agglomération et on sera
prêt pour relever ce grand défi de la
vaccination roi d'abris merci à mes deux
invités en eau péricard en
visioconférence maire de saint germain
en laye est également le docteur laurent
de basta est médecin urgentiste à
l'hôpital privé de versailles est
également vice président de l'ordre des
médecins à des yvelines merci d'avoir
été avec nous et j'ajoute que nous
reviendrons bien sûr sur elle les
mesures qui seront annoncées à partir de
19h dans notre émission de demain le 7-8
week-end présenté par eléonore sinoquet
avec un invité le député des yvelines
didier baichère la vaccination continue
aussi au vélodrome de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines et a même pris
de l'ampleur cette semaine 2
ce lundi 15 mars seiler centrale de
l'édifice sportif qui a été investi plus
de 100 professionnels sont présents sur
le site à 16h ce jeudi 18 mars plus de
13000 personnes ont été vaccinées depuis
l'ouverture du site en janvier et dont
un tiers a déjà reçu la deuxième dose
les propos recueillis par mélanie poker
on est sur une vitesse d'environ 1500
vaccinations par jour ce qui nous place
d'heures dans l'est dans les très gros
structure française une des plus grosses
et en fait on se prépare à passer à la à
l'étape supérieure encore on n'est pas
le plus touché par la pénurie mon lait
un peu on aimerait on a une capacité ici
on peut multiplier par par 5,5 à 6 le
score d'aujourd'hui rs tient compte de
l'effort qu'on ait fait donc le
gouvernement le cabinet ne se verront
aussi vous à passer quelques messages
aussi voilà ils tiennent compte de
l'effort d'organisation
de l'investissement que vous faites dans
cette crise qui est quand même inédite
qui est grave la direction versailles à
présent la cité royale aux 10 millions
de visiteurs chaque année de touristes
annuels connaît une période délicate
avec la crise sanitaire depuis un an les
hôtels les commerces et les restaurants
tourne au ralenti et doivent s'adapter
pour éviter la fermeture
le reportage de mickaël millero et de
célia de 400 go et luxueux palace fermer
temporairement des touristes qui ont
déserté le château fermé au public
versailles est en première ligne face à
la crise sanitaire dans cet hôtel situé
à proximité des anciens appartements du
roi soleil
les temps sont durs seulement 5% des 18
chambres de l'établissement sont
réservées le week end et 60 % la semaine
un taux d'occupation inédit est
historiquement bas 30% du chiffre
d'affaires de l'hôtellerie en règle
générale à versailles dépend directement
du château de versailles
donc c'est 30%
de chiffre d'affaires de toute façon on
ne les a tout simplement plus et bien
sûr en plus de l'impact économique est
déjà crise sanitaire
nous avons un impact majeur sur nos
hôtels actuellement même constat
quelques mètres plus loin dans cette
boutique installée cours des senteurs à
côté du château
la crise a frappé ce concept store qui
vont à la fois des cosmétiques de
l'épicerie fils de la décoration a vu
son nombre de visiteurs / 5
la structure a perdu environ 10% de son
chiffre d'affaires mais un nouveau type
de tourisme a émergé ces dernières
semaines des touristes beaucoup plus
locaux beaucoup plus yvelinois beaucoup
plus franciliens etc des touristes d'une
après midi on a des touristes du
dimanche après midi par exemple c'est
vraiment très spécifiques et on a
beaucoup de touristes qui viennent
redécouvrir versailles le temps d'un
week-end donc nous on a des clients
parce que ces touristes veulent ramener
un petit souvenir pour faire face à la
baisse de touristes la ville de
versailles a mis en place plusieurs
actions
les visites spécifiques ici est orienté
vers telle découverte ou tel ou tel type
de promenade architecturale vous avez
des promenades aussi découverte cartes
et artisanaux versailles et promenades
vertes scission avec le physique oui
c'est découvrir tous ces éléments
végétaux on a développé tous qui a eu là
encore ils tous les acteurs du tourisme
attendent désormais la réouverture du
château de versailles et le retour des
touristes internationaux pour pouvoir
revivre normalement avant l'épidémie de
kobe 19 la ville accueillait près de 10
millions de visiteurs dont 80%
d'étrangers
dans l'actualité également la fin de six
ans de travaux sur la route
départementale 30 entre plaisir et
elancourt dernière étape la mise en
service de la passerelle piétons
cyclistes au niveau du bois de la crâne
c'est désormais chose faite
l'inauguration a eu lieu hier mercredi
un ouvrage de 52,2 50,2 m de long 4
mètres de large qui permet de relier le
bois de la crâne au parc du château de
plaisir deux parkings ont été également
aménagés de part et d'autre de la rd 30
coût total de l'opération 1,9 million
d'euros écouter ses réactions aux micros
d'astrid bergère aujourd'hui on arrive à
une forme de finalité avec une attente
forte de déplaisir roi puisque non
seulement bien sûr il ya tous ces taxes
qui nous permet d'avoir une circulation
beaucoup plus fluide et puis un
désengorgement de la collectivité mais
en cuisse maintenant il ya une aisance
pour les piétons et pour les gens qui
vont aller se promener en passant d'un
parc à l'autre on va dire du château
jusqu'au bassin du bois de la crap dans
les yvelines
il n'est pas possible de remplacer la
circulation automobile par de la
circulation piétonnière ou ciddist
l'ampleur du territoire l'interdît il
faut donc faire cohabiter toutes les
formes de mobilité n'opposons pas une
mobilité à une autre ce serait une
erreur grave et une erreur qu'ils
rejetteraient nos concitoyens et bien
souvent nos concitoyens les plus pauvres
qui n'ont pas d'autre choix que
d'utiliser la voiture pour aller à leur
travail
l'opération de renouvellement de la rd30
s'accompagne d'un important volet
paysager avec près de quarante mille
plants sur une surface totale de
paysagement est de 20 hectares 1,4
million d'euros sur quatre ans pour la
qualité de l'eau dans grand paris seine
et oise la collectivité a signé ce
mercredi avec suez l agence de l'eau
seine normandie le contrat territorial
au et climat vallée de seine
l'objectif finances et sensibiliser à
accompagner les acteurs locaux dans la
préservation de la qualité de l'eau et
la sauvegarde des milieux aquatiques est
la démarche est parti d'un diagnostic
sur le territoire de 410 mille habitants
les eaux souterraines sont pollués un
pro
homme d'action a donc été définies
notamment quatre airs de captages
prioritaires et aussi favoriser la
conversion des surfaces agricoles en
culture bas niveaux d'intrants voir en
culture biologique
un programme financé à hauteur de 80 %
par l'agencé de l'eau seine normandie
autre signature mais ce jeudi au peg
celle d'un partenariat entre le réseau
entreprendre yvelines et le groupement
des entreprises des boucles de seine un
projet pour accompagner ensemble les
entreprises du territoire depuis leur
création jusqu'à leur développement dans
le but de rompre l isolement des chefs
d'entreprise les deux associations sont
complémentaires et interviennent à deux
stades différents écouter les au micro
de justin brasier raison à prandelli
n'intervient au niveau de la création d
entreprise et le jeu bs anime toutes les
entreprises déjà existantes elle
rapporte certain nombre de services d'un
point de vue technique administratif
logistique l'idée fait au travers de ça
que les entreprises se développent et
ciel se développent elles ont beau
chasser votre raison finale quand même
aussi le but c'est de travailler
ensemble de faire du réseau de croiser
les compétences de croiser les que que
loger obs nous envoie éventuellement dès
lors est d'aider futur lauréat
qu'on puisse nous les accompagnait avant
de refermer ce journal elles aussi ont
décidé d'unir leur force 2 yvelinoise
vont prendre le départ du premier rallye
électro féminin un évènement 100%
électrique et 100% féminin qui
s'élancera de versailles le neuf le 9
mai prochain
portrait avec michael et demi d'euros et
patrick jacques de dixmude 1-2
yvelinoise se lancent à l'aventuré
juliette 48 ans originaire de versailles
axel 39 ans de verneuil-sur-seine vont
participer au premier rallye 100%
électrique et 100% féminin le dépeint
sera donné le 9 mai prochain depuis
versailles
un projet inédit qui a séduit les
participantes là c'était vraiment
l'occasion d'avoir un rallye en rupture
un rallye complètement différent où
l'objectif c'est pas un objectif de
vitesse mais c'est vraiment il ya
vraiment une notion
d'environnement et de respect de
l'environnement puisqu'en fait il va
falloir relier un point à point b en
limitant l'énergie consommée au maximum
pour réussir à parcourir l'ensemble des
800 km de cette course d'orientation les
deux aventurières comptent sur leur
complémentarité
elle travaille ensemble chez
l'entreprise yvelinoise vd com
spécialisé dans l'immobilité autonome
c'est une collègue que j'apprécie
beaucoup on est très complémentaires
moi je suis plutôt la communicante elle
s'est plutôt l'ingénieur fans de mecha
et on s'est dit qu'à nous deux on allait
faire une très belle équipe on est
complémentaires niveau professionnel
mais aussi au niveau personnel
on a des qualités complémentaires axel
elle est très organisée sont bonnes
gestionnaires
moi je suis plutôt la créative
enthousiaste donc je pense qu'on va bien
s'entendre
cette amitié sur un soumise à rude
épreuve pour lancer six jours de
compétitions le trajet se fera
uniquement avec une carte et une
boussole sans téléphone ni gps pendant
que les véhicules se rechargeront les
équipages devront poursuivre leur route
à pied dans les montagnes sur 10
kilomètres chaque jour un programme qui
n'effraie pas les yvelinoises en
espérait dans les trois meilleurs
équipages bien sûr puisque sont les
trois premiers qui seront récompensés on
est douze équipages et bien sûr va on
espère trouver les balises le plus
rapidement possible puisque l'objectif
c'est de trouver des paniers sur un
parcours qui est tenu secret jusqu'au
jusqu'au jour j
l'équipage recherche encore des sponsors
pour pouvoir participer à l'épreuve elle
espère boucler leur budget avant la fin
mars
c'est la fin de ce journal merci de
votre fidélité belle soirée avec télé 78
[Musique]